hello everyone i'm alana
that's yusuf yusuf would you like to
introduce some
hello my name is yusuf uh you may know
me from working at ubisoft uh or hosting
ubisoft forward or things like that uh
yeah i
i don't know what else to say
sure those are the things that i do
for a paycheck and we are defined by our
jobs excellent yes uh that is new huh
who are you
hello i'm nuha uh i am a narrative
designer in the games industry i'm
currently working at respawn on the next
star wars jedi game uh before that i
worked on a vr game at archie act and
also worked on far cry 6 at ubisoft hell
yeah and then below me are two people
who've been on the channel before we
have uh tamar who are
i'm tam i'm managing editor of gamespot
and
general internet troublemaker that's my
official title at least he knows
yeah and then we have rami right here
romney what's your introduction
i am an independent game developer slash
industry human
yeah he wrapped it up pretty well
yep it's good solid i have gathered all
you lovely people here today to talk
about something that has nothing to do
with the games industry unless you want
it to um everyone on the panel today is
muslim and uh happy ramadan everybody i
basically wanted to take this
opportunity to you know use a video game
channel mostly to talk about what
ramadan is what it actually means like
what what do you what do you have to do
and why
essentially for anyone who isn't kind of
familiar so that's my first question how
do you describe what's going on right
now i think i think tom had like the
worst best explanation i've ever seen of
ramadan i was gonna say that did i
actually i don't know which one you're
talking about because i wasn't talking
it was the lore drop oh yeah yeah i
describe ramadan as a celebration of
when the month where all the good muslim
law dropped which is effectively a way
to gamify the idea that the quran was
revealed to to mankind
um but yeah and i described it as
imagine if vati dropped all his soul's
law in one month
um
which is like you know it's true am i
wrong tell me i'm wrong no i think my
next my favorite other analogy you made
is that it's like double xp month yes
it's double x
so if you're doing good stuff yeah you
do it this month you get double xp um
but if you do bad stuff it's like a
massive massive debuff on you because
the idea is in the month of ramadan like
all the evil kind of like uh temptations
and the things in the world or the
spirits or whatever they may be the evil
angels that are out there um that tempt
you on a normal year are locked away
for the month so anything you should do
that is shitty this month is entirely on
you you did this yourself it's just you
yeah you so you are the reason this
happened no no you can't blame no evil
spirits on this issue
you feel really bad really bad about
yourself even if you say a swear word or
anything you're like oh no yeah you've
seen my twitter i say any swear word on
on twitter and it's hard not to swear on
twitter like for the record that's
that's some that's hardcore
uh i i just admit it goes stuff i like
like this like a way of saying like
sorry effectively yeah so you do try not
to swear
the entire month just
it's
it's kind of it's hard you need to
really really to do a good ramadan you
probably have to delete twitter
otherwise you're just not gonna make it
it's just
i think the thing i i always go back to
um and that you know everyone knows
about the abstaining from from food and
drink um
yeah during the day
uh until until sunset but the thing that
that i think always gets slept on and is
the thing i try to be much more caught
instead of because honestly when you've
been doing this as long as i'm sure we
all have you know you just kind of get
used to the no food and water and it you
know
we all build in various ways to to cope
with it um but to me it is that part of
practicing patience and kindness and
good will towards others um
and and not having immediately negative
visceral reactions or when you you know
just trying to remember that even if you
do just
calm down take a deep breath you don't
need to get upset at someone like
you know we're all just human beings out
here trying to do our best and that you
know just because i'm fasting and
someone who's not fasting you know
complains that they're hungry you know
that's fine it's okay like oh is that
fine because i make everyone feel
incredibly gilly i used to see i used to
do that and then
you know like i i'm like try i'm like
really trying to be like a more like
mature better version of myself you know
that's the difference there that's the
difference between you and tom thomas is
like no let's go no i am i'm out here
starting fights like this morning i was
in a meeting with a colleague and she
was like oh i just need to get this
coffee down me and i just like whispered
into the mic sorry for some of us isn't
it
so
so to back it up ramadan is the ninth
month of the muslim calendar it's a
lunar calendar so our months are not
actually like
solar months
so every time the new moon starts it's a
new month
and when it hits the ninth month
that's the month of ramadan and ramadan
is not a special word or something it's
just it's kind of like saying september
yeah
it just happens to be that september is
a really really like specific month
where certain rituals happen
um and during ramadan is it different in
in different places because i know that
there are some places where like if it's
winter they don't have they have less
sunlight
right how does that bring ramadan from
sun
from the first light of day and i think
technically it's defined as the moment
where you can distinguish your shadow
from the darkness the first light of day
until the moment the disk of the sun
sets fully under the horizon muslims
have to abstain from consumption
which includes any sort of consumption
so uh food drink
sex
if people smoke smoking which is always
fun to watch muslims try to stop smoking
in the three weeks before ramadan
also coffee really funny like muslims
that are really like big coffee drinkers
you can just tell like about three weeks
in advance when they get a little like
shaky it's like oh
they're getting ready
um
that goes for from the new moon to the
new moon so
uh you know i i don't know how it is for
y'all but for for me
it was always as a kid sitting in front
of the tv listening to this old imam guy
the sheikh this the scientist person
going and this guy just keeps talking
and he's going to announce whether they
saw the new moon so whether you have to
start fasting tomorrow or whether you
get an extra day before ramadan starts
because it's really dependent on whether
the moon gets seen
the new moon
and this guy just like it's like it's
like a talent show you know one of those
voice whatever shows where the jury
already knows who they're gonna announce
as the winner but they're just gonna
drag it out as long as possible that's
what it feels like it's like when the
anime catches up in the manga and they
need to buy time
it's just like we got a kill time quick
yeah we're just gonna gonna gotta talk
about how this whole thing happened but
so is that a global announcement
no so it's per community okay
yeah so so there there have been times
where there was a new moon sighting in
the middle east but not necessarily in
you know on the west coast here in
california interesting that that the
days might not necessarily line up it
also means that like rami said you don't
you don't know exactly when ramadan is
going to start until the night before
and you don't know exactly when ramadan
is going to end until the night before
just brutal
oh i took that a very different way
clearly i've not done it i mean
it's both but after 28 days if you're
like oh
are you tomorrow yeah the end of ramadan
is our biggest celebration of the year
right like ramadan is already sort of a
festive communal thing so it's already
like
a really good time
for muslims
but then i eat at the end is
bonkers
like it's just food it's feasts it's
going to family and getting this at
least in egypt we do something called
idea
which is where you go to family members
uh or or friends of the family and you
basically get a little monetary gift
yeah
right
uh so i would go around and get some
money yeah and then go buy video games
right that's that's quite interesting
what are your other experiences what do
you guys do on eid
well eat lots of sugary food yeah
like a lot street food there's morning
prayer
right prayer which is a longer prayer
um
we go out there here so we go around to
family friends and get money and we
usually get new clothes
just like nice
nice
new clothes mm-hmm do anyone have
different experiences yeah
uh mine are like i so mine
is everyone else here egyptian
what about you where are you from i am
syrian okay syrian so pakistani i i'm
interested in hearing what syrian um eid
is like but pakistani is like
so it would wake up we'd wake up i'd do
a
uh go straight to prayer come back and
then do like a little prayer that is
like small amount of family like the
house prayer basically which is like it
would be me my mom my brothers my sister
and my dad and sometimes like my
granddad would show up and then we'd go
around to individual houses
and then also like do similar stuff
there um that's when we were younger
nowadays as an adult i'll do like the
main prayer and i think that that like
weird going around here everyone's
houses is like a cultural thing more
than a
more than a actual like islamic muslim
thing and as i've grown up i've start
i've like learned to separate pakistani
cultural practices from islamic
practices
and like since becoming my own adult
i've just been like now i'm not doing
any of that
call everyone i'm doing the main prayer
and i'm done now so i'll like do that
and then just bounce um
like my eids are always this is gonna
sound really anti-climactic real boring
like super boring like because
most of my family are super boring as
well so i'm just like you know what i'm
just gonna stay home me and my brothers
are gonna hang out at home we're gonna
eat food and we're just gonna play some
video games and then we'll probably just
bounce
so what i'm hearing is we're going to
invite you to a
arab like
he has already he already hasn't
yeah i'm just going to eat potluck
i'm excited but i also have to like
because my parents or like my mom
specifically is like no we're gonna do
like a a video call eat together and i'm
like
somehow you have made eid worse for me
[Laughter]
i mean i can kind of relate to just
because uh i don't have much family here
in canada
like all my family is mostly still in
syria so when it comes to eat gatherings
they're really small family gatherings
and then they kind of like slowly as we
got older
it cut we started kind of drifting away
in a sense so my eids are basically just
hanging out with my close family like my
parents and my sister
we go to the mall and we go get
food and eat out we go to usually get
like brunch
somewhere like it's very basic stuff but
like we do it together and we just make
it feel special but it's not as big and
grand as it used to be when we were in
syria when we had like all of our family
members and we rotate between different
houses um throughout the days uh
and it's very different even just the
festivities there as well like
everything's lit up there's just a
different vibe going on over there as
well
i think that's really easy to sort of
miss is that ramadan is the biggest
event of the year
yeah for the muslim world
because i was about to say actually i
think you'll find the biggest event of
the year is e3 so
rip
true
this year for this year this one year
it's ramadan otherwise it's the second
most important thing yeah yeah right for
sure um
but you know it's literally the biggest
like life changes and especially in the
muslim world like
most of us live in in the west uh but in
the muslim world this is like
world defining like days shift into the
evening right people wake up later um
work starts later or there is no work uh
um
there's celebration there's lights in
egypt we have like these little lanterns
uh called phonies
that like hang everywhere the the
mosques are lit up in in green light or
in colored lights
um
at the end of the day there so at the
start of the day we have a meal called
which is your or different ways of
pronunciation between all of us probably
but
um
arabic and
islam are exist around the world so a
lot of words come from one place and
then sort of like
get dialected around the world
so who does like a morning breakfast
usually sort of a family meal if it is
within family context it can be quiet um
but it's usually sort of like a i do you
all have that experience of waking up
really early and your parent is like
telling you like
let's go
and you just hear like the most absurd
sentences because your brain isn't awake
yet and you're just sort of laying in
bed going but if you miss it you can't
eat right
yeah so are you really particular like
do each of you have meals that you
choose to eat for that morning to keep
you going all day
oh man
i'm sure this is like a question that
you've been asked before but so i don't
know i always relate to horror too to
like that feeling of like if you ever
had to like wake up in the middle of
night to use the bathroom and you're
trying not to be like to fully wake up
so that you can go back to sleep more
easily it's that but you're trying to
eat a meal yeah it is so i used to eat
like uh when i was a when i was younger
i used to eat like really heavy meals
like we'd have like this thing called
paratha which is like
it's like a a naan bread but like very
oily and and i'd have it with like a
curry and it messed me up every single
time like i'd wake up feeling like
refried ass and like
every night i would carry on doing it
and then as i got older i was like i'm
gonna be smart about this and just start
eating you know like um like toast or
like uh oatmeal and then i got even
older when i was like
i just don't want to get up so i just i
just like get i i like open my eyes
chug some water and then go back to
sleep and i'm like i'll deal with this
i'll deal with the consequences later
and let me tell you i am dealing with
those consequences right now yeah it
sounds like middle you had the right
balance then kind of threw it out the
window just i would do the same thing i
think yeah i prioritized sleep i was
like i'm concerned i'm the same exactly
tim i wake up and i drink water because
because otherwise i honestly and romney
and i have talked about this i will
overeat during ramadan it's actually far
easier for me to do that because you
spend you know 16 hours awake not eating
and then when by the time you you can
you just want to indulge it's almost
like you've been jeet by accident yeah
then you sleep which is even worse
because your metabolism is just like i
just ate a whole bunch of stuff now my
body is going to do nothing yeah for the
next like eight hours and then i'm gonna
eat again
yeah i'm gonna not eat
it's really hard to stay awake after
you've eaten too
like you just crash and you just wanna
go to bed immediately but i'm like
trying to keep myself awake like no or
else i'm really gonna like feel it in
the morning but you can't you your body
just doesn't want to do anything
afterwards every time i have chipotle i
popped out exactly i have a tweet draft
that says can science twitter tell me
why every time i eat chipotle i have to
take a nap and i think it's the salt
not sure now imagine that if that was
every single day with any meal like yeah
it's like it's wild my mom always used
to yeah
my mom always used to say it to me like
before we start eating she'd be like
remember your eyes are bigger than your
stomach right now yeah and it's just
like a good way of saying it the other
thing is like technically you're
supposed to
like at the after you're breaking your
fast and having that meal you're
supposed to go to the mosque and pray
tarawi um which is like throwing prayers
are
they're like the lord of the rings of
praise they go oh
a really long time
and a lot of it like you tune out for
you
and like you're just like there's
moments where you're just like gently
swaying on your feet trying to remember
what's going on
and it's rough it is rough you broke
romney
you i've seen you been you've been using
apps or something romney to help with
prayer i got i so i i know how to
because prayer in islam is is a lot more
straightforward than a lot of people
think if you can remember like 20
sentences you can technically do every
prayer that you need to do for your
entire life like that that's it it's not
super complex but
you can do option if like to make it a
time metaphor you can do optional
difficulty modifiers yes yeah so you can
you can just remember like these 20
sentences or you can do a prayer that's
like 25 pages so you like you don't go
get the shackles before you fight
margaret yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly
yeah yeah yeah
during ramadan in a lot of in pretty
much every mosque they try to to do a
prayer with the entire quran
effectively from start to finish
which is pretty intense and near the
start just nothing happens because the
start of the quran is the longest
yeah
so you just go into the mosque and they
stand still while somebody prays a surah
that you don't remember probably yeah or
like
not fully remember
or yeah
never really memorized in some cases
yeah just kind of stand there for like
what is it like butter it's like
half an hour yeah there's some that are
like really really long way like it
honestly depends on the imam if some of
them are really milking it then like
yeah you're there you're there for 40
minutes yeah i i had one who was like
bro i've got the best voice and
everyone's going to hear it
he monologued it he was like like
putting in like he's he's like extending
notes for a really long time and if
you're like come on but then as you get
towards the end you start picking up you
reach the point where it's a lot of the
surahs or the passages that you know off
by heart and like you have because you
you've been reading them since you're a
kid and then you start getting a rhythm
where you're like i know exactly when i
get to go into the next position and i
can like stretch my legs a bit and i
know exactly how this is going to end
it's real good
um but these days it's been kind of it's
kind of been kind of interesting because
i haven't been going to travia as much
for the last couple of years because
i've covered um and it's been kind of
it's weird where every fast doesn't feel
complete in a way but also you have to
kind of just grapple with the idea that
this is how it needs to be
for a really long time um and like i
know that from my local mosques like i'm
gonna be honest with you religious
people they are like the super spreaders
of the last two years like because
they're like no i don't ma it doesn't
matter to me i'm still going to a lot of
those churches out in florida yeah a lot
of churches a lot of mosques like i i
remember like kovid was kicking
everyone's ass like in the heat of it
and people were like yeah i'm scared to
the mosque and i was like oh you know
you are like 95 years old like are you
sure you should be doing that and
they're like yes god will protect me i
was like
god don't protect people against idiots
that's all i'm saying good luck man
god doesn't tell you to cross the road
with your eyes closed yes exactly look
left look right yeah um but
so
we're doing the worst sort of like
jumping from so at the end of when the
sun sets we do another meal called iftar
yeah and that one everybody also kind of
has a meal to break that's the one you
keep napping afterwards by accident
after every meal yeah okay at this point
yeah um
so if that is sort of like and that's
like a big one because that in a lot of
muslim countries that's super communal
so in cairo they have like a table
that's like i think 1.5 kilometer like
whoa
0.7 miles there's something you can
google pictures of it it's amazing
that's awesome
and it is a communal table so people
just bring the co go there people bring
food food gets put out if you're rich
poor doesn't matter anybody
can just join that table sit down and
have a communal meal and it's like a
really big celebration thing
and iftar is really meant to
it's kind of meant to be done together
like if you can't do it together
you know
that's okay like there's nothing in
ramadan that is like if you can't do it
or if it's bad for you you have to do it
that's not what ramadan is that's not
what islam is like
if it's bad for you don't fuss right if
you're sick if you're elderly if you're
um on your period if you're pregnant if
like whatever it is like then don't
not like you don't have to just
don't
um
but
for iftar like to do it communal is a
recommendation
yeah so a lot of people will go out go
to family like noha sets sort of like
rotate between different houses to have
iftar or go outside and it's
it sounds awesome also these pictures i
looked up the table a beautiful
it is it is a lodge table
this is actually the first year i've
tried
made a
concerted effort to actually expand my
my muslim community and people i know
and as a result have been you know going
to guitars or you know hosting eye
potlucks and things like that and it
there's something about it where you
know you'll be in a room with complete
strangers because
one of the things i love about this
thought is that like it's an open invite
essentially like it is it is not like
hey we we don't know you it's not no new
friends it's no hey are you a muslim are
you did you just move here maybe you
know did you do not know anyone come
eat it's fine like we're all gonna get
to know each other we all we all have a
shared experience we all have some sort
of
shared belief and background and you
know we're we're
going to just
sort of have this
cathartic moment at the end of every day
together
and we're going to be closer you know
because of it yeah when i was in england
my local mastered my local mosque the
headmaster there was my or the the main
imam there was my teacher
and um his policy was everyone from the
community is allowed whether you're
muslim or not so he would invite
non-muslims in he had that he had a very
interesting way i learned most of my
best islam from him um i also learned
from my granddad my grandad is like an
imam too but he's ultra conservative and
doesn't know the difference between
culture and religion so i didn't learn a
lot of good things from him he put me in
that mosque because one of his friends
were there and he was like he'll learn
the same kind of islam that i teach but
i very quickly graduated out of his
class and went to my headmaster the
teachers who i who taught me primarily
and he was born and grew up as a hindu
um and then converted or reverted
technically
depending on your perspective to islam
so he chose to be a muslim
and
the way that that works out better
because most people who inherit the
religion rarely take the opportunity to
understand it um but he like he came to
it because he read about it fell in love
with it and then began teaching it and
his policy was anyone from the local
community is allowed so we'd have people
who are christians we'd have people who
were like atheists coming in and like
they'd sit down with us and have a meal
and we'd talk to them and just like hang
out we'd never try and tell them about
the religion they'd just be there and be
like yep that's cool and then he would
encourage us his students to kind of
take the the food that was left over and
create like little packages and then go
out to the local community and find
homeless people and give it to them
awesome so so like we did that when we
were young and it was like such that's
the kind of experience that you're
trying to you want to get out of ramadan
yeah
that's so cool i mean that sounds great
i also love what you have touched on
earlier about
you know you say that you're trying not
to react to people or lash out at people
or whatever that's essentially self-care
what you're doing is spending spending a
month
bettering your own behavior in a way
that should last throughout the year
you're actually like internalizing your
reactions to things and thinking about
it in a way that i
never do like i don't have any time
where i'm like i should think about
bettering myself i just think i do it
every day but the fact that you have
like a focused time to be like how can i
be a better human is awesome
yeah it's something i i always try to i
mean honestly like
it's it's
it's super easy on the first day of
ramadan and it feels really good and
like you're like yes like i'm you know
i'm above it i'm above the nonsense and
the bs and then you know life happens
and hits you and and you know things
you know start to get away from you but
i i try every single year you just get a
little bit better about about
remembering and like carrying that
forward because like that is
you know one one we fast for a lot of
reasons like one of them and one of the
ones i i think about a lot is is empathy
of it of like okay
i'm you're you're
going without for you know
an entire day for a month
in theory and hopefully that that helps
you build empathy for people who
go without not by choice and and you
know allows you to
be more giving of yourself and
not just with food or money but but with
your emotions with your time with with
you know your empathy and
you know
just because someone does something that
angers you maybe
you can just back off and and try to see
it from their perspective or try to
understand that hey not everyone feels
the same way you do and that it's okay
and
to me it's always a very contemplative
month and i always spend a lot of time
reflecting um maybe it's just because
i'm not busy planning my next meal all
the time
but
it's it's i think that to me is is is
what i tried to take away um every year
was on
would you say you agree with that was it
like yeah a hundred percent agree let's
see like exactly the same way like i've
kind of been raised to like look at
ramadan
it's almost like a spiritual reset in a
way like you look forward to it and you
realize like all the things that we've
had and we've taken for granted and you
kind of like realize what and be
grateful for what you have
and there's like also the other aspect
of ramadan which is charity where we
actually give a lot of money we donate a
lot of money to the islamic communities
around us around the world um we do we
have this thing called zakat which is
like one of the pillars of islam where
we donate a small percentage of our
earnings per year to charity
if you are able to um and that's
something that people do especially
during ramadan which is like the month
of giving
especially to the homeless and people
who need it
yeah the little the little care bags
that uh tam was talking about
uh we do those in egypt you can buy them
in the supermarket pre-made they're just
sitting near the entrance of the
supermarket you just buy them and
there's a lot more poverty and
homelessness in egypt so you can just
buy three of those bags and just
give them
to people and it's just just
it's a good way of people sort of like
taking a a conscious moment to think
about things and whether it is empathy
or community or family or
thankfulness or discipline because
that's a part of ramadan like whatever
it is that that you
get out of ramadan it is
almost by definition sort of
contemplative and self-reflective
because you're just confronted with
yourself in many like for me i run
around a lot of airports
you just notice
how much time you spend at airports
going like oh let me grab a snack
yeah and i i'll be standing in the queue
to buy a snack and go like
ah and then i want a curse and i go like
don't curse
because out of habit yeah like like you
said i do spend a lot of the time during
the day thinking about what i'm going to
eat next like a lot and yeah you're
probably right that when that's that's
the thing that's
specifically scheduled there is a lot of
time to think about
other things you care about i i think
about when i'm gonna have my next coffee
constantly i don't think it ever
disappears from my brain i think that
one of them i was talking about this on
one of my streams but like
i i encourage everyone to try fasting
even just for a day because
you never
truly valued the ability to walk to your
fridge and fill up a glass of water and
just drink it at any moment up until you
fast for a day and don't have any
because
every single day that first glass of
water after you break your fast
you like
the gratitude you have for it is like
unbelievable it's unparalleled and then
that when you have that moment you're
like i'm so glad i can finally have this
your brain automatically snaps to what
about people who can't have this who
don't have this and then that feeds into
what nuhou was talking about which is
charity that's encouraging you to like
think about the world around you and the
people who aren't as privileged as you
are to be able to fast for a little
while and then have the food to recover
from it and in fact their life is one
eternal fast where they just do not have
the ability to
to eat and drink whenever they please
um and then hopefully the idea is oh i'm
gonna give to charity and try and help
people around the world in that in those
situations
all of this sounds awesome and i feel
bad that i'm just drinking this nice
lemonade right sorry for some isn't it
it's okay it's between it's between it's
between iftar and for me so it's fine
for two of you and it sucks for the
other two i see that natural light
bathing on yusuf's face yeah there's
some thistles on here
just in your mind going challenge
accepted yeah
is it uh is it long days over a year
yeah because here in the netherlands
it's like 18 hours i was talking to some
some friends that are on on the southern
hemisphere and they're like yeah we just
have late breakfast and i'm like oh yeah
well
so that's the other thing we didn't
specifically especially say you know
rami mentioned because it
it follows the lunar calendar that means
it doesn't sync up with ours which means
that it gets about 11 days earlier every
year so when we were all young it was in
the middle of winter
at least in the
which which meant that you were breaking
fast at 5 00 pm
yeah like you know you i was i was
eating if tar before i normally eat
dinner and you know you i was waking up
first a [ __ ] and just staying awake
because it was it was basically already
time to wake up um so
it has since progressed earlier and
earlier and you know a few years ago was
in the middle of summer during the
longest time of the year last time
during e3
yes yeah the most the most blessed of
holidays converging yes yeah the world's
two biggest holidays yeah right together
yeah bringing the two biggest religions
in the world muslim islam and gamers and
e3 and the esa
so
the yeah the days being different but
it's still global so there would be some
people right now who have short days
kind of like what rami just touched on
and then in theory right now it's a
little bit longer for you in california
yeah but if there are like weird
exceptions to where like if you live
super far north or super far south where
it's 22 hours of sunlight a day or the
opposite 22 hours of darkness a day then
the the ideas that you're supposed to
fast the hours that they fast in mecca
oh okay yeah
you're not you're not beholden to your
terrible you know time zone or anything
well also applies to the international
space station according to a
statement made a few years ago because
they now have muslims in space and it
turns out praying towards mecca and
keeping to say oh we're in space now
this is really we're in space now we're
not always moving for you now the rest
of the world
is over
we've made it i had no idea we've made a
space you are in trouble now
oh so how how do they pray to mecca on
the international space station when it
is
in constant rotation when you're
constantly floating around and moving
basically they can just pray towards
earth here's the thing i i firmly
believe i firmly believe that god has a
sense of humor so i imagine god wherever
this this entity is is just looking at
them trying to stay in one orientation
and laughing
uncontrollably
um that's one of the things that i like
i i try and
tell people is like
one thing i really hate and it's
something i had in my upbringing is when
religion is taught through the lens of
fear which is like it's something that
constantly happens non-stop it is like
the the context of teaching religion is
if you do this you will go to hell and
one of the things that i i learned from
my um teacher there the hindu who
converted to islam was it doesn't have
to be that way like you can think of
why would why would like this benevolent
being this god create all of mankind
just to make sure just to keep an eye on
you and trip you up so you ultimately
burn in hell it doesn't make any sense
what sort of fear of consequence has no
moral value yeah exactly and like for me
like i always tell my younger brothers
and anyone that who like seeks advice
from me about religion i'm like hey
don't be so uptight about it like if you
feel like in islam
in ramadan like hey i don't feel good
today i i don't think i can fast today
don't put yourself through it just to
just because you think that you're going
to go to hell just imagine that
you know this
your god is very reasonable and it's
like you know what
i believe it like it sounds like you're
having a shitty day don't worry about it
come up with some other way because
there are ways to make up for it like
some you can do it outside of ramadan
you can fast or you can i believe it is
you need to pay you can
you can give to charity the amount it
would cost to feed a person the entire
day
um and that makes up for a fast um i
think that's it depends on
interpretation depending on like your
where you're from and that kind of stuff
but um
there is a charitable element to it um
so i'm just like chill man everyone
relax i mean and tom touches on
something that's also really important
to understand is that islam is not one
thing there's many verses of islam and i
don't know who said it but it oftentimes
really intertwines with local culture
and separating the two can become really
hard unless you sort of get the an
outside lens and start seeing the
differences
so
uh you know like uh
the things people break fast with the
exact times at which the sun goes under
there's like four major schools of
calculating what time the sun goes under
right
uh
the the sort of rituals that go with
ramadan the the
the way countries calculate when ramadan
starts and ends
the local traditions when it comes to
suhur and iftar the way we celebrate
the foods that come with aid right like
some countries have like these very
specific suites some
we don't we don't even agree about
whether our baklava has like what what
what goes into it like it's like
whatever it is there's disagreements
about it across the muslim world um but
that also makes it really wonderful in
in a really lovely way that you have
this thing that is your own but you can
also learn from these other people and
since i've been doing the the habibi
sort of uh podcasts with with uh arab
slash muslim
sort of focus
um the things you just learned talking
to people where you're like i thought i
knew kind of what islam was but then you
realize there's just a million there's
two billion versions of islam yeah right
and i i'm i'm on on
in that regard i'm very close to tom's
interpretation of like okay it's a thing
when
for allah in islam they have like 99
names and most of them are like nice
things
you know they're like you know like the
the the beneficial or the merciful or
like the you know those kind of names so
it's kind of like okay just
yeah chill like ramadan is not meant to
it's not meant to torture you or put you
through a wrangler it's meant to slow
you down
look at the world around you appreciate
what you have understand that some
people don't
do that that spiritual reset that nuha
was talking about which for me is a huge
part of ramadan and then when ramadan is
over you actually kind of miss it
you just you just really like sure you
have the moment where you have like your
first you know the sun is up and you
have a glass of water you're like
[Laughter]
but like
after that you're just kind of like
you miss it i really miss it it's just
it's gone it's like
oh yeah he's right yeah
i miss it but also i very much don't
miss it
i'm gonna be 100 honest with you
i miss it from a spiritual perspective
but i'm also like hell yeah i can have a
coffee again
the coffee it's it's really whether you
drink coffee or you smoke yeah that
really defines whether you're missing
yeah yeah
i i think the thing i always think about
too is that you know similar to the you
know
doing something uh because you're afraid
of retribution isn't you know isn't
morality um
in in the same light i try to think of
that in the same way of you know good
deeds and you know tam said that you
know it's double xp you know your good
deeds count for more and then later you
get into ramadan it's they they count
even more so um and
you know when i was younger i would you
know like i would always kind of think
of it as a as a tally game of like okay
i'm i'm banking up all these good d's
i'm banking up all these goodies that's
gonna offset all the bad i've done
throughout the year and there are a lot
of people who still who think that way
but i'm again like it's like i'm trying
because
you know at time romney were saying and
you know
like i i firmly believe that like allah
is like a reasonable
uh like entity and being and that that
like they they do not
like they're not sitting there in
necessarily counting check marks and
tallies and they they understand if you
know you did something
um without knowing like i was for
example like i was at a i was at a
housewarming that happened to have a lot
of muslims uh and they you know they
someone ordered pizza turned out one of
the pizzas had like pepperoni or sausage
on it and no one realized until after
the fact after a bunch of people had
already eaten it
and no one no one batted it or not
it's like the person who ordered it felt
so bad felt so terrible
running around informing her own
apologizing everyone's like it's okay
you know
we didn't know we didn't knowingly do
this we didn't you know knowingly eat
pork no negative intent
yeah exactly and like i that's always
what i kind of try to go back to is that
like allah is is going to at least
consider your your intent that like you
know i intended to fast
something happened and i couldn't or you
know i i made a mistake i i accident i
forgot and i accidentally drew that used
to happen to me when i was younger you
know that like okay that's that's fine
like you can you can make it up you can
there are allocations almost none of the
five pillars of islam probably besides
faith are absolute musts there are
always
there are always ways and it's you know
it's if you can if you can afford to if
you can travel if you can if you're
physically able to pray if you are
wealthy enough to donate if you are
healthy enough to fast those are all
there are all sort of asterisks to
everything to accommodate and you know
i've i've found my experience with islam
that
i i
it accommodates
sort of who i've grown into and who i've
become and how i've how i've
viewed the religion and viewed it within
my own personal morals yeah 100 i think
like the most important i've always had
these situation i've been in various
situations where people have been like
why do you believe in this nonsense and
i'm like well think of it this way
i i would like to hope that you think
that i am a good person like i try and
be a good person i'm doing my best and
i'm
trying to help you know people around me
or at the very least you consider me a
friend you know that kind of thing and
if that is the case you have to also
accept that everything that i am was
shaped by my religion and my belief in
that so if you want to respect me
you have to respect that religion
and that is the way i feel like
i've approached everything or i've
helped i've told other people like to
treat religion whereas like look at the
person
like are they a good person
if so yes you know if yes then that
should be a reflection of how you should
treat their beliefs and the belief as a
whole um because i know people now who
don't believe in in
god but they're like no i don't believe
it but i have a friend who is muslim who
is super nice and like i can only think
good things about their beliefs because
they are that person they are shaped by
that uh by that belief system as well as
you know the upbringing and that kind of
stuff but that played a major factor and
yeah it's like what you said it's like
it's it's not a scary thing if you if
you allow if you come at it with a kind
of like
a good heartedness and a genuineness to
it it can be something that's empowering
more than kind of like disarming i don't
feel like i have the authority to speak
on this but in in my head it feels like
the
operating out of fear of punishment
or consequence constantly would would
just rack you with guilt i feel like
that would be a very negative way to
live and it would be very difficult for
you to feel good about yourself
in the long run
which as tam pointed out there are a ton
of people who who teach the religion
that way yeah yeah um and i think that's
that's often why a lot of people bounce
off of it or a lot of people that are
raised in it end up rejecting it easier
to teach kids it's kind of lazy exactly
like negative reinforcement with you
know kids for some reason is tell me
santa's not going to give me presents
i'm good all year that's how it works
that guy is real right
uh in our in our religion no he got he
got he got often the first arc
there's a fatty bit about that
that's also how i was raised i it was
super strict for me and that's like you
know kids and and whatnot and i feel
like when i grew up and was older i
realized like one of the
the 99 names of allah is like the
all-forgiving so he is he will if you
seek forgiveness he will forgive you and
that's how we kind of move on and become
better people is because we don't have
it that that guilt that you're talking
about a lot of like we don't
hold on that and that just helps us move
on and just keep becoming better and
treat each other better too i think like
if you learn to be all forgiving to
other people as well that's going to
make you a better more awesome person
too and even if it it's accidental or
you've done something and you regret it
later you can still seek forgiveness and
like it doesn't have to be like a whoops
i didn't realize that it could be like
you did it intentionally and you were
like no i should have not done that and
then you kind of learn from that so seek
forgiveness and you learn and you just
become a better person that way and
ramadan really does that really enforces
that
i promised rami that we wouldn't do this
for too long because of the time so i'm
sure we could talk about this
for days but is there anything that
anybody would like to add before we sign
off
i think from for most actually two
things if you know somebody
that fasts
it's a proper way of of congratulating
somebody with ramadan it means blessed
ramadan effectively
and i think the second one
as tam said uh if there is some sort of
communal iftar or a day that you can
fast or something that you can be a part
of just for once to see what it's like
and to sort of see the joy that comes
around
i love the idea of that community you
like sold me on trying to go to egypt
during ramadan it sounds awesome
yeah i need to go i've never spent the
rumble on it that'd be awesome
and the only thing i currently try to do
is i try not to swear and i try not to
send really bad memes to muslim friends
during ramadan oh this is wrong muslim
tick tock is on fire during ramadan it
is good greatest it is the little
greatest thing there was this video
going around
one or two years ago
of a guy sitting in a car
and then grabbing a twix bar
and like unwrapping it and then he has
one of those sunroofs in the car and he
just looks up and he goes
and then he closes the sunroof
like the funniest thing ever
oh it is so good it's just a mess it's
brilliant
there's also like there's also like
chefs like muslim chefs that they're
like i follow quite a few like chefs on
instagram and they're like they make
normal stuff and then they come it comes
to ramadan and they're like no i'm gonna
really put you through this and they
like makes make the most ridiculous
things and you're like you weren't going
this hard outside of ramadan why are
just like please chill no one can eat
any of this stuff
that's why that's actually my favorite
thing sorry i know i know we're going
along but like
i as someone who loves cooking myself
like cooking during ramadan is
so
surreal kind of because you can't taste
anything as you're going along and you
know like you have no idea of what
you're making how did it cook
yeah because you you can't taste it in
like
sauces could be terrible
but and i don't know what it is i don't
know if it's like divine intervention or
it's because you're feeding a room full
of people that haven't eaten all day but
the meals are always the homemade meals
always taste amazing yeah
always helps put salt on the dish right
after you try it there's always salt
that's missing yeah it is always salted
even when you're cooking like you can't
even look a spoon you can't lick off
like a wrapper or something if you like
pull like a wrapper off a yogurt you
can't do any of those little things like
you're about to do it you're like oh no
i can't nope stop stop can't do that
like the little things you don't realize
and then the moment you realize you
can't do it you can't curse which is
yeah
that's the extra you're like
oh there's that there's that if you if
you're like me you're so paranoid well
there's that moment where you're having
a shower and a little bit of water like
it goes and you're like
oh i'm just sitting what does this mean
like spitting in the shower
[Music]
so when is this the current ramadan
expected to end
on the second or third of may okay is uh
it's prediction and
that same imam that that sam sheikh
for most communities is gonna sit there
and have another 35-minute monologue
the equivalent of a drum roll that goes
way too long
at a party where nobody wants to know
the big reveal
uh that
uh and then we're either gonna hear
whether we fast another day or whether
we're gonna just
eat too much or have a rating boring
heat depending
because that means that you can't
actually prepare the meals
for it to be
over
as someone who was planning on hosting
potluck i like i sent out a tentative
invite for monday may 2nd but it's like
it could be tuesday maybe tuesday
hard potluck yousef that's a bit mean
you'll like bring food on this day maybe
i know i'm gonna have to take an extra
day off just in case
maybe and worst case scenario we all
can't eat it yeah yeah bring the food
we're just gonna sit there and stare at
it but we all just we're all wait five
hours for a tower yeah
we won't be able to eat here but we'll
be able to take some amazing instagram
photos yes just like throughout the day
alrighty thank you all so much for
joining me this was awesome it's very
nice to chat to you about it uh let's go
with juice where can people find you
yusuf
uh i am at yusuf mageed on basically
everything um instagram twitter
those are really the only two things i
use but yeah at yusuf nikki how about
you
i am on twitter my handle is nuha not
noah
as a story for another time
mainly i'm there
tim
uh i'm at tomorrow h on pretty much
everything
and romney's just technically
he's got his whole zoom
thing
efficiently
a underscore rami or on instagram tha
dot rami they didn't let you have the
underscore on instagram they didn't let
me have to underscore devastating
devastating yeah someone someone on
twitter i've been trying to get my just
my first name on twitter and for the
longest time it was an actual published
author that was very popular and like i
was like you know what i'm never getting
this and then i checked randomly the
other day and the published author is
gone now summer complete randall is
squatting one
will smith who
a lot of us know um
the
harassment he got after the slap
yes he's verified and it's at will smith
it's so unfortunate
every time um but yes anyway
happy ramadan everybody i hope you're
having a wonderful time thank you for
chatting with me and thank you to
everybody for watching i'll see you next
time
[Music]